[Music]
there's a weakness in the window place
my footprints in the dark roomm there's
lonely voices like a scarecrow in the
hallway like a lost ghost in the bedroom
I see a sh from the Moon with light from
a candle on a bed frame lies a girl her
reflection in the
[Applause]
mirror I like your eyes
wiing at your back
door nervous like a
[Applause]
night
what you ask for I do this from time to
time where I can never wait from a bad
dream I do this from time to time where
I can never say the things I
mean I do this from time to time where I
like to watch you as you
sleep I do this from time to time where
I like to think of you with
me
[Music]
it's a dark night on the west coast and
a soft Breeze as the sun rose then the
phone ring like a gunshot like a siren
on the beach rock there's a message at
the river a certain package here to
deliver when the day breaks
after Nightfall I will be there you know
I
will I like your eyes
w at your back
door nervous like a night
F what you this from time to time where
I can never wait from a bad
dream feel this from time to time where
I can never say the things I
mean I do this from time to time where I
like to watch you as you
sleep I do this from time to time where
I like to think of you with me I can
hear you breath I'm feeling the shake
and the sound of my heart
be can let
go
you no I'm feeling the pain of my first
love I let it
go can't let go I do this from time to
time where I can never wait from my bad
dream do this from time to time when I
can never say the feel I
mean I do this from time to time where I
like to watch you as you
sleep I do this from time to time where
I want to taste you as you
breathe I do this from time to time
where I can never wait for my bad
dream I do this from time to time where
I can never say the things I
mean I do this from time to time where I
like can watch you as you
sleep can do this from time to time
where I can e of you with
me
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
uh I kind of fell in love with that song
from Angels and Airwaves a few weeks ago
brought it into the dance studio with me
a couple weeks ago and uh wrote a brief
bit of choreography and wanted to see if
I could integrate that into a longer
flow piece and what do you know totally
worked out um so real quickly I just
want to put out a huge thank you to flow
toys for sponsoring this video and
giving me a reason to go out and explore
new places in DC like the one that I I
found for that video uh flow toys you're
awesome and if you all out there would
like to grab yourself a set of those uh
flow moja LED contact boy that I was
using in this video you can do so by
using the code drexfactor
1224 at checkout that gets you a
discount and it helps out the channel so
everybody wins once again that is Drex
Factor 1224 thank you once again to flow
toys y'all are awesome and speaking of
thank yous I owe a big thanks to the
Friends of the channel that is big
thanks to uh dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling py tire
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible uh if you want to learn
more about all these different companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself you can go
ahead and check out the links that I've
got down in the description of this
video and finally a big thank you to uh
the non- business friend of the channel
That is Becca Becken thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission
Kos um also uh this video would not be
possible were not for my awesome
supporters on patreon in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now over here in fact um if you like
these videos if you like seeing me
produce content like this the best way
to support it is to head on over to
patreon and sign up you can do that at
patreon.com Factor poo every time there
helps out the channel and helps me keep
on making videos like this one so go
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like to check out more
performance videos that I have done over
the years like this one I will include a
link to a playlist of those videos down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow with yourself today and
I'll see you in the new video real soon
take care now peace